good morning John what really blew me
away is the sense of community the sense
of excitement all of this energy that's
surrounding this event seeing how
YouTube changes first VidCon I ever went
to I was a viewer so I watched things
like this but out then I was right in
their video to me is a way to make
people feel like they belong you are
basically the early pioneers of a new
and differently that wasn't seeing
people like me represented in television
this is my first VidCon and I feel very
old
we need and others but in the long run
[Music]
maybe now's the time to put down your
pencil and just go have fun
[Music]
watch
what you come
[Music]
VidCon 2016 the seventh annual VidCon is
gonna be a thing June 23rd to the 25th
in Anaheim and registration is available
now because VidCon 2015 went pretty well
we're basically going to be doing the
same thing we did last year just with a
little more will have more stages will
have more space we'll have more special
guests our goal with VidCon has always
been to reflect the state of online
video and thus as online video has grown
so has VidCon but one thing that we
haven't been particularly good at
reflecting I feel like is the explosion
in gaming content and I feel bad about
that because streamers and YouTube
gamers are huge it's a huge thing and I
feel like we just haven't been good at
inviting that in and making it a
priority at VidCon so I really want to
do that this year in order to make sure
I do like at least an okay job of that
I've just been trying to understand the
YouTube gaming world and the twitch
world as well it's so diverse it's so
huge of you people watching want to
suggest any gamers to me or any
interesting things in the gaming world I
should check out please do that in the
comments I'll be looking for things that
will be pretty much the same we have the
same tracks the Creator track the
community track and the industry track
and the settings and photos will be
ticketed the same way they were last
year with a lottery where you rank your
favorite creators and the based on your
preferences and availability you get
some signings and that way I don't have
to wait in line for hours and hours and
I know some people do want to wait in
line for hours and hours but first-come
first-serve is how we did it in 2014 and
that turned out kind of bad they're
completely unrelated to VidCon news the
project for awesome is gonna be December
11th and 12th so if you want to make a
project for awesome video you got to
start thinking about it if you don't
know what the project for awesome is
that we will be talking more about it
during pizza miss if you don't know what
pizza miss is I'm about to tell we
celebrate pizza miss here on the
vlogbrothers Channel and last year we
celebrated that with two weeks of
brotherhood 2.0 style videos which means
a video every weekday from one of us
Hank or John so starting Monday there
will be a video every weekday for two
weeks and it will be great and in
addition to that we do a bunch of
limited edition Pizza John shirts this
is one from last year you will not be
able to get it this year but you will be
able to get a number of very cool ones
that I will not show you until pizza
mess begins which it will on Monday with
my video and then John I will see you on
Tuesday